so there was a fantastic article by a
guy called Henry wise Meyer and it was
called the death of aw in the age of
awesome and basically he was saying that
the urge for these profound encounters
with something else with other nough
students of the new has become a new
religion he basically says as
spirituality wanes experience is the new
faith and we are refugees from the
mundane this makes a lot of sense that
faint disquiet that hunger for
Baudelaires anywhere anywhere haunts our
dreams Alain de Botton famously said how
pleasant to hold in mind through the
crevices of our moods at 3:00 in the
afternoon when lassitude and despair
threatened that there is always an
airplane taking off for somewhere
Baudelaires anywhere anywhere a
wonderful book called drugs and travel
in 20th century literature makes the
same case that seis basically says that
drugs and travel are so discursive ly
similar they use the same motifs of
mobility and transport because they're
ultimately talking about the same thing
hallucination means to wander in the
mind from the etymology of the word I
Lucy natus so you see my friends this
desire for altering our perceptions this
desire for other Nisour the idolization
of experience for a virginal noticing of
the sense8 world for a sense of first
sight unencumbered by knowing this as
part of what it means to be human that
desire for an encounter with the
mysterium tremendum a fastened awesome
poles and beckons at us it's f scott
Fitzgerald notion of a transitory
enchanted moment when man must have held
his breath compelled into an aesthetic
contemplation we might not understand
nor desire face to face with something
finally couldn't measure it
to our capacity for wonder Carl Sagan
said understanding is a kind of ecstasy
we are Wonder junkies and at the end of
the day my friends I may utter these
words in these moments of enraptured
prose being ecstatic articulation in
rapture vocalization but at the end flow
bear said human speech is but a cracked
kettle on which we tap crude rhythms
while we long to make music that will
melt the Stars melt the Stars